métamorphose un mot simple en apparence
métamorphose du temps qui passe de
l'objet de la personne 17 des adhérents
du photo club élan courtois se sont
prêtés au jeu
on se donne un mot chacun bon c'est
sérieux c'est pas toujours évident à
matamoros nous apparaît bien compliqué
où le mot on laisse voyager l'esprit
l'imagination mais c'est toujours un peu
compliqué après de remettre des photos
fixes dessus et bon bah ça on l'a laissé
à mûrir pendant un an à peu près en
faisant des petites revient de temps en
temps et puis dans l'es7 et compter dans
l'année dernière un an de travail où
l'oeil des photographes amateurs et
passionnés s'est posé des clichés
singulier classées par thématiques ou
les éléments attirent l'oeil et ressorte
au propre comme au figuré
le principe consistant à remettre en
relief donc à revenir vers l'objet de
l'image à plat revenir vers l'objet mais
des choses sur sur la mort ce qu'on
constate dans la nature sont voit dans
la nature simplement les transformations
de matériaux des choses
sur la façon dont les gens ont pu dire
s'approprier des matériaux exotiques et
puis beaucoup de choses sur les reflets
sais c'est bien assez facilement
l'esprit 17 points de vue qui donne à
voir ce qui peut échapper à notre oeil
pour que le regard lui aussi se
métamorphose